in monsoon lash Myanmar we're on a
journey few foreigners are now allowed
to make
this is northern recline a place where
thousands of rahaga were murdered raped
and fled for their lives we're here
because the government wants to show us
it's now safe for refugees to return
that looks like somebody over there Pete
Celeste but first we must pass the
remains of their former homes how many
people fled how many how many would have
fled from that area that we but
officials don't want us to focus on
these scarred grounds can we stop so we
can just see that bit when we finally
get out of the car it's clear why our
minders didn't want us to stop for this
bit but you can see evidence immediately
of lots of burning fern wood there on
the ground a huge charred area as well
and some sort of discarded furniture and
this we're told is one of the areas
where the reinga were living before they
fled look all along the road are the
blackened remains of buildings
that's just villages isn't it weeds now
grow where houses once stood they cannot
hide the signs of violence more trashed
furniture plots
so they look like plots there the
further we explore the more destruction
we find this site is just a few minutes
down the road from the other one and you
can see even clearer signs that people
were living here pots some sort of
cooking equipment boxes all of it just
completely destroyed and deserted
refugees say this damage is proof the
military torched their homes and
murdered their families in revenge for
attacks by rahaga insurgents but in
Myanmar officials have a different
explanation
you should accident all then directly
the accusation is baseless but at a
nearby government built village it's
repeated as there is a deep mistrust of
Ranga here it's claimed Muslim
terrorists murdered eight more villagers
refugees would not be welcome back we
can't wait that long
despite the opposition the government
insists it's safe for a hinga to return
this repatriation camp has been open
since January inside we meet a group of
regular who were told came back from
Bangladesh but it's soon clear that's
not the case has anyone been to
Bangladesh yes
no he says no so none of these people
have been repatriated from Bangladesh in
fact not one refugee has come to this
camp from Bangladesh and officials are
clearly frustrated I don't live alone on
it Malala is at work well Lizzie and
ethology
how about you you re learning is
tomorrow
you can actually see Bangladesh in the
distance there were around 700,000
reinga are now living in camps but if
they did agree to repatriation they come
to this line of huts in front of me
they're to be verified and then be moved
into this camp for several days before
being moved on to another but many of
them say they won't come back because
they fear for their safety thousands now
wait in mega camps in Bangladesh until
their rights are guaranteed but as we
reach them in my border it's clear the
situation is more dire
this is no-man's land for those stranded
behind the fence aid is restricted help
limited how many people in the camp
[Music]
through the wire dil Mohammed tells us
they're desperate and alone the camp is
badly flooded they cannot sleep food is
scarce the facilities may be ready but
Myanmar's repatriation plans seem a
distant dream many we met still view the
Ranga as the enemy and until their
safety and freedom are guaranteed no
refugees will return here
Siobhan Robbins Sky News northern
recline in min MA